l'actualité de ce début de semaine c'est
donc la démission de françois de ligne
et le maire vient de tenir cet après
midi une conférence de presse au cours
de laquelle il a expliqué qu'il
souhaitait pas c'est leur passer le
relais au bon moment rappelant qu'il
avait déjà prévenu que ce serait son
dernier mandat
il faut savoir préparer l'avenir sans
s'accrocher à son poste
écoutez il ya une décision de passage de
relais et pourquoi maintenant
parce que avec d'état d'esprit que j'ai
indiqué c'est à dire celui d'une
préparation de l'avenir
je sais que c'est le bon moment parce
qu'on va pouvoir travailler en
continuité parce que la majorité
municipale présentera la candidature de
marie christine le tarnec qui était déjà
dans responsabilités d'adjoint dans le
mandat d'avant on peut partir quand on
est avec une ville en forme et en forme
soi même une page qui se tourne donc du
côté de guyancourt maire de la commune
depuis 2002 le socialiste françoise
deligny avait pris en cours de mandat la
succession de roland nadeau entré au
conseil municipal en 1989 il avait
également officié en tant qu adjoint
chargé de la culture
l'ancien instituteur qui s'était tourné
vers la politique aura également été
conseiller départemental de 2008 à 2015
il ne va pas quitter le conseil de
guyancourt il va également resté
conseiller communautaire jusqu'en 2020 à
saint quentin en yvelines et c'est donc
sa première adjointe marie-christine le
tarnec qui devrait lui succéder
l'élection aura lieu avant le mois à
deux aides décembre je vous propose à
présent est d'écouter quelques réaction
est tout d'abord celle de sandrine
grands groupes c'est la responsable
départementale du parti socialiste elle
a longtemps travaillé à ses côtés elle
va continuer à travailler avec lui au
sein de l'agglomération
je suis à la fois un petit peu triste
parce qu'on a pris l'habitude de
travailler avec françois de ligne et
depuis depuis quelques années et en même
temps le chef il avait que de la
division kidal un fait rare en politique
des hommes politiques qui est abandonnée
de même des fidèles de mettre un terme à
leur mandat de maire il fait un pli à la
fois dans les pas de houdan nadeau et en
même temps il a réussi à donner sa
propre impulsion qui fait pas toujours
ce qu'on fait un four table quand on
arrive après avec quelqu'un
avant tout il ya une blague ou encore
madonna pag les fortes personnalités et
30 revenir assure imposer sa marque
on peut être à la fois parfois très
directif dans et très avoir une
politique très un fils il est en même
temps que très respectueux et plus
proche des gens pour l'agglomération de
saint quentin toujours michel laugier le
président divers droite de saint quentin
en yvelines tiens à saluer son
adversaire missiologie acquis l'an
dernier l'a remporté face à lui alors
des élections départementales france ou
de lenny avait déjà annoncé que c'était
sûr donné mandat
la seule incertitude c'était de savoir à
quel moment elle allait faire son
annonce à quel moment il allait passer
le relais nous sommes les meilleurs
adversaires puisque déjà nous avions une
commune d des communes voisines annonce
avons souvent à travailler ensemble et
puis surtout ce qu'il y avait d'autres
élections nous étions face à face voilà
avec des succès pour lui dans son métaux
et des succès ensuite pour moi dans un
deuxième temps voilà donc je suis pas
surpris je pense qu'il ya de sages
décisions lorsque il faut savoir passer
le relais du côté de l'opposition
municipale à présent écouter le point de
vue du chef de file les républicains
ladislas secours a été lue depuis deux
ans à guyancourt et il ne semble pas
très surpris lui non plus de ce départ
il est derniers mois et des dernières
années d'un petit peu compliqué avait
des sujets brûlants des dossiers
importants
il est très possible que que cela est un
petit peu touché la gouvernance et
monsieur des lignes et plus
particulièrement il vient et rythmant
non on peut le voir de manière à les
progrès lors des conseils municipaux
frictions au sein de sa majorité
quant au groupe modem toujours à
guyancourt son représentant s'est dit
surpris par la date mais pas du contenu
rapportent nos confrères du parisien et
que pensent les habitants de cette
démission de leur mère qui restera je le
rappelle au sein du conseil municipal
mais aussi au sein du conseil
d'agglomération de saint quentin
micro-trottoir signé patrick jacques de
dixmude et anne-laure langues
c'est ta mère que j'ai apprécié dans des
circonstances un peu particulières ou
sein d'un ca d'un établissement scolaire
donc je pense qu'il était ouvert et
surtout l écoute des enseignants donc je
suis domaine de demandeurs d'emplois est
donc
je enfin les services de l'emploi ne
sont pas trés trés on va dire efficace
exactement parce que j'ai fait plusieurs
demandes je n'ai jamais jamais eu de
réponse qui est des problèmes mialouh on
appelle le maire et tout téléphone et ou
de laon la direccte au filet tous ya des
problèmes psy si par exemple on a des
problèmes de 2,2 d'appartements pour se
loger ou valve vous pouvez le voir
directement lui en parler tout ça c'est
pas mal voilà les quelques réactions
suite à ce départ de françois de lignes
et de son poste de maire de guyancourt
le socialiste elle sera remplacée à ce
poste nouvelles élections au sein du
conseil municipal d'ici le mois de
décembre et puis je précise que le maire
de gouy encore n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer pour le moment directement
face à notre caméra pour répondre à nos
journalistes